[Music]
one thing we've learned during this
pandemic is how hard it is to pull off a
live show
but the inauguration special was
spectacular i mean just seeing that
right now my breath is still
taken away we have got all the great
behind-the-scenes moments that you
didn't see but
the story about the fireworks themselves
it's gonna blow your mind
[Music]
as katie wrapped up that epic
performance her man orlando bloom was
shooting
this touching behind the scenes video
that was awesome
baby which included a kiss
i love you i love you
i love you orlando wrote one day our
little girl will grow up and see her
mother play her part
in a moment in history
cbs this morning's gayle king who helped
anchor inauguration day coverage
was so impressed she reached out to the
pop star
i texted her this morning to say katie
you killed the song
and you look great doing it bravo a plus
plus plus plus
and then did you see the biden family
dance thing and there's a reason katie's
fireworks were so intense
producer ricky kirschner and director
glenn weiss told me this morning that
the time frame of the pyrotechnics had
to be condensed
from seven minutes down to just four
there were three cameras inside the
white house
and the whole show was produced from a
nearby hotel ballroom
security was so tight it took celebs an
hour to get through
justin timberlake pre-taped his
performance of better days in memphis
with rising star ant clemons
they performed with students from the
stax music academy
when did you find out you were going to
do it justin called me
and said your jedi minds tricks are at
master level
i'm like what do you mean justin
timberlake he's like i don't know how
you did it
but you did it and my pr team just got a
call and
uh they want us to perform for the
inauguration
and i told them that you had to check
your schedule
other standouts john legend john legend
it's a new day i mean john always sounds
great but i thought
last night he added a note or two
everybody john bon jovi here
everybody sang with such feel and notice
the song
[Music]
choices
yup if the inauguration had a theme it
would be hope
and unity country stars tim mcgraw and
tyler hubbard
in nashville performed their new song
undivided
there's a hopefulness to it which yeah
without hope what do you have
[Music]